[Music]
look
the games we play are great but they can
be glitchy as hell
all those random infuriating
malfunctioning bits of code
suck when they happen to you but they
can be even more annoying for pros
one bad glitch can cost a pro an entire
tournament
so today we're going to take a look at
the bugs
over esports top players but before we
get into that i want to remind you guys
to subscribe to the channel if you
haven't done so already
that way you'll never miss a video just
like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 glitches over
the pros
kicking us off at number 10 we have an
absolutely
out of this world incident that happened
during the 2019
pub g global championship back at the
bus
yeah yeah sometimes crazy things happen
and uh not great for poppins but the
rumblers player
cherry poppins was driving a car through
the game when it crashed into a building
but instead of exploding or becoming
unusable
pubg's engine sent the vehicle straight
into the stratosphere nice headshot from
on to xiaolou oh oh my goodness what's
just happened he's gone to space
okay bye-bye when the car finally came
down
it exploded knocking cherry poppins
unconscious
and leaving his prone body at the mercy
of the other players
who were quick to finish the job his
cosmic adventure could not
engine physics one cherry poppins zero
well we'll pray for you cherry oh
no not like this not like this indeed
and he's going to get picked off too
silent
uh you know he what can you do
taking the number nine spot is darshan
and the unfortunate
minion block that cost him his life
during a match between clg and immortals
at the nalcs summer 2016 playoffs
actually moved their duel into the mid
lane as well to try and pressure that
central section of the map to open up
space for this infernal and darshan is
just taking a beating
yeah and this physical damage from huni
oh he gets the stun oh that's the good
news there joshua going to try and get
himself out of the way rooney
does pick up the kill face dives onto
his face
up after getting trapped by the pesky
bug for about eight seconds and falling
to huni
darshan attempted to call for a pause to
get the issue sorted out
sadly for him the minion block was
deemed a normal part of the game
and clg had to take the l on that one so
this is it right here
minion blocked can't move it's a normal
thing in the game
talks about pathing issue and he can't
get out of it fast enough and that's why
he gets stunned there
and he wasn't able to get out coming in
at number eight we have
flamey's knife taking on a mind of its
own yeah that's the thing i i think this
navi squad now uh
we'd love to see that again maybe maybe
just what happened
now as much as they suck team kills
happen but to be fair
they're mostly accidental and are
usually kind of hard to avoid
usually but during an esl pro league
season 10 match
when flamie's knife stretched across
time and space to stab
simple to death it wasn't flamey's fault
at all
so what is this about then
oh what you know i've done that before
when you didn't even see him though he's
got he's got a full 360 harry that's a
double-edged knife right there
cs goad indeed everyone's smiling having
a great time simple doesn't it
coming in at number seven is an aurelian
soul bug that interrupted the match
not once but twice over the course of a
summer 2016 playoffs match
between clg and tsm as soon as the
fortification is gone from the top lane
turret
clg has been very disciplined about
going up there as soon as possible
tsm has paused because of a suspected
bug on
clg so they're actually investigating
that right now but it looks like
they have cleaned up all the suspicions
and we'll get back into the game
a few moments later oh good barrel slow
right there
this game is keeping you anxious right
now and even more
so you were speaking to being anxious
a little bit after the glitch appeared a
second time it was ultimately decided
that the game would be remade
and aurelian soul was disabled tsm
actually had a ward in the blue buff
and off on the side you could see
aurelion saul's orbs orbiting around
but he wasn't actually there he was in
mid lane while the matchup was close
enough
where it was hard to say who exactly was
screwed over the most
the consensus was that it was probably
clg
yeah it's a really rough situation i'd
say probably more so for clg because
they're the ones that have huhi
who's been playing aurelian solve for so
long and now they can't play it in the
series
coming in at number six is a player who
has had his fair share of bad luck
karrigan but the mishap that kerrigan
encountered at dreamhack
open tours 2019 really takes the cake
during a mouse esports versus valiants
match he shot someone square in the head
and nothing happened he could get this
gun
there is a player cat though oh no he
hasn't done it he's been
killed no not like this you really hate
to see it
you just hate to see it man did he just
get mega cs gold though i
it looked on that's the crazy that was
my first reaction is that hit him in the
head i would love to see a replay of
that [ __ ]
yeah that's so ridiculous there's no you
cannot
wait let's just hope that someday lady
luck is planning to pay kerrigan back
for that one
i'm glad we got to see that whatever
fault you had for kerrigan wipe it off
the board delete your reddit threads
the man deserved the headshot there
our fifth entry is brought to you by
blizzard and their shoddy remaster of
warcraft at dreamhack anaheim 2020's
warcraft reforge tournament
thor's aim was about to take a victory
off of one of the best warcraft 3
players out there
moon when the game disconnected we have
no breath of fire by the way
it is drunken haze so big miss chance on
these dragon hawks
and a disconnect
i'm gonna assume thousand dropped but i
feel like moon was
on the way to holding this attack oh
wow that fight was the most
important one in this game yet well [ __ ]
happens right
the two then played a rematch that was
also cut short by a premature disconnect
costing thor zane yet another sure win
once this
and looks like another drop just happens
oh wow their third game ran without
issues
except this time moon took the lead and
won
and the tournament lifeline of the swede
is relying on tanks even as an ap
and torso is just gonna tap out moon
moves on to the semi-finals where you
will face foggy later today
absolutely master versus apprentice
coming up you cannot
uh yeah you have to feel bad for thor's
lane that's for sure
that is one protracted loss for poor
thor zane
thanks blizzard coming in at number four
we have proof that not even the great
fallen is immune to getting csgo'd
the smoke molyburg caused smoke grenades
to be completely useless against
molotovs for a time
ending in many a fiery death for pros
and non-pros alike
plenty of players fell victim to this
bug but none more prominent than
fallen who got burnt to a crisp at esl
one new york 2017
starting off a key round of overtime
with a hot molly bath
molotov's doubled up again fallen same
example has to fire through
glitches and the smoke nearly costs him
as he goes down to two hp
so he loses this smoke his eighth big
please valve
here's the smoke we were discussing that
should pick the flames out but sometimes
it does bug out
and doesn't go off fallen didn't go down
because of it but certainly
didn't help his round taking the number
three spot
is a moment where plop learned that
sometimes you can't even trust the
ground beneath your feet
i love it i look at this that's right
the crowd is right
sdj just rolled with it too he was just
like stop
stop stop yeah great in shine 2018's top
eight pluck was facing off against
s2j on pokemon stadium things were
looking pretty good for plops fox but
then
s2j grabbed him and yieted him clean
through the stage and into the shadow
realm
all right can suj put together a johnny
stalker we get to see club go up 2-0
for the first time could we see oh what
the hell
are you kidding me the pokemon glitch
in top eight and shine unreal
freeze this map freeze this man even
though this wasn't the first time this
had happened
the chances of plop falling through the
cracks at that exact spot were
minuscule fortunately though pluck
bounced back from that disastrous bug
and won the set 3-1 and i think that is
gonna do it the shine will
end the set what a again we had that
moment
we had our our sort of game-breaking
moan right there but again
congratulations to club just proving too
fast too punish heavy
imagine completing your in-game
objective and popping off in celebration
only to be killed by the opposing team's
sole remaining member because the timer
kept
going it's panic on the streets of
london as we try to work out what has
just happened
as unlikely as that sounds that's
exactly what happened to faze clan's
call of duty roster
at cwl london 2019 which is why they're
taking the number two spot
on our list selling zooma they're in and
amongst these zoomers
and to save my goodness but i think the
zone
didn't i don't even know what happened
there here it is
um look at this look at the red bar the
red bar is contested
he's contested right now slack slides in
the zone he's gone
and just to prove there's no justice in
this world the referees were rather
unfazed by the whole situation and ended
up ruling in lg's favour
[Applause]
and finally taking the top spot on our
list is the moment cs goes chickens fall
back love them or hate them chickens are
as iconic a part of cs go
as its legendary maps and skins but at
star series eye league season 4
rops fell victim to one of the feathered
menaces when a chicken
killed him by standing in front of a
door and effectively blocking rox's only
escape path
fur has done a massive job ten seconds
left rox has to hold on to his
gun chicken blocking the door i've not
seen that before if that gets him killed
oh my god a chicken blocking the door
just got robbed killed
obviously falling prey to a glitched ai
bird sucks
but considering the way some players
treat them perhaps it was only fair
there's no justification for having them
in the game absolutely not but you can
press e on them and they can follow you
that's true
all right there you go guys those were
some of the glitches that really
over the pros which one of those was
your favorite did we miss any out that
really should have been
on the list let me know thanks for
watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
hello one corner off
corner dead come on what the [ __ ] what's
going on here
i'm gonna fall back via control there's
a chicken there i bet
i can't open this door t apps what the
hell
it was a [ __ ] chicken